es realmente estos estos estos
encuentros funcionan estos acuerdos
funcionan que está pasando y que podemos
hacer para tomar ya cartas en el asunto
es que no podemos seguir jugando con el
tiempo marina
sí y parece que los políticos creen que
sí que tenemos bastante tiempo por
delante obviamente también está toda la
agenda política que tienen ellos en
mente pero es verdad que no podemos
seguir posponiendo de una cita a otra de
una cumbre a otra lo que necesitamos
hacer hoy como bien decía el presidente
de namibia que estaba ahí presente decía
está muy bien que nos reunamos está muy
bien que hablemos que hablemos pero lo
que necesitamos es actuar actuar ya
mismo y poco a poco esos acuerdos que
iban anunciando acerca de por ejemplo
combatir la polución plástica en las que
eeuu y francia y van a querer
implementar maneras de hacer que la
economía circular es decir que el
plástico no termine en los mares sino
que se vuelva a utilizar y poder evitar
que llegue a esos cuerpos de agua
van avanzando está muy bien pero eso no
va a hacer que sea en una realidad hasta
que los países se comprometan con
acciones reales
algunas de estas anuncios que hacían por
lo por ejemplo tampoco vayan a van a ser
vinculantes y ese es el problema de
estas grandes cumbres internacionales
que muchas veces lo que se decide y a lo
que se compromete en los países no es
vinculante es decir no tienen el marco
legal y no tienen por qué ser cumplidos
lo mismo pasa un poco con la cop 26 como
bien decías yo estuve en glasgow el año
pasado y es un poco frustrante ver como
una y otra vez mes tras mes se van
reuniendo los políticos y al final los
que más hacen son las pequeñas
comunidades que están al frente de la
lucha contra el cambio climático de la
lucha contra la contaminación plástica
también muchas iniciativas privadas por
ejemplo de recoger los plásticos en los
ríos en los cuerpos de agua antes de que
lleguen al mar así que finalmente yo
siento que a pesar de que el
financiamiento viene muchas veces de los
países y de los gobiernos nacionales y
estatales los quienes más hacen son los
actores privados compañías privadas que
poco a poco se van comprometiendo con
este problema al que nos enfrentamos
hablamos de plástico marina pero tampoco
hay que olvidar las redes de pesca que
se quedan pues obviamente olvidadas en
estos océanos los animales son víctimas
de todas estas redes también el
vertedero india como uno de los
principales contaminantes de nuestros
océanos hay que ver también se va a
comprometer el gobierno indio para pues
dejar de contaminar en nuestros océanos
también hablamos de todos los derrames
de aceite sobre todo el petróleo pues
hay muchas cosas sobre la mesa marina
muchas cosas para hacer pero también
antes de despedirla quiero que nos
amplio un poco muy rápidamente sobre la
importancia de los océanos es que los a
porque entonces ahora todo el mundo se
está volcando y sobre todo el énfasis
que hace el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón en el cuidado de nuestros océanos
bueno es que los océanos lo hemos dicho
varias veces son los reales pulmones del
planeta no tanto los bosques tropicales
como veníamos diciendo absorben una gran
parte de las emisiones de co2 que
emitimos los humanos a través de todas
nuestras actividades como la quema de
combustibles fósiles y son esenciales
las corrientes marinas son las que
dictaminan los ciclos del clima de los
patrones climáticos del mundo entonces
cualquier desequilibrio que sufra el
océano se ve reflejado en
nuestros ciclos de lluvias de calor o de
frío en las estaciones que por ejemplo
tenemos en el hemisferio norte o en el
hemisferio sur no tanto en las zonas
ecuatoriales pero todo eso depende de
que el océano mantenga su equilibrio y
todas estas actividades que mencionabas
hacen que poco a poco se vaya
desequilibrando el océano sus
ecosistemas y por no mencionar además
que tres mil millones de personas
dependen
el océano directamente para su
subsistencia no solo para comida como
tal sino del turismo de muchísimos
muchísimos sectores que dependen
directamente de este cuerpo de agua que
cubre más del 70% del planeta que bien
lo dije en una intervención anterior se
llama tierra pero que se debería llamar
agua porque es el planeta azul al fin y
al cabo